Google's CEO is speaking out after the
tech giant canceled a town hall meeting
intended to address a controversial memo
by former employee sundar pichai had
planned to discuss the widely circulated
document which criticized the company's
diversity initiatives he said the
company was forced to call off the
meeting over safety concerns for staff
last night pitch I spoke to teenage
girls at a coding event Carter Evans is
outside Google's headquarters in
Mountain View California Carter good
morning good morning the company-wide
meeting was canceled just about 45
minutes before it was supposed to begin
now Google executives are figuring out
how to respond to employee questions
about the memo and about the company's
firing of its author Google CEO sundar
pinch I plan to use Thursday's town-hall
meeting to address some of the more than
500 questions submitted by employees but
in a company-wide email Thursday pitch I
said he canceled the meeting after the
questions were made public and some
Google employees were named online
leading others to worry they might be
outed publicly for participating
Thursday's meeting was expected to focus
on the widely read memo which argued in
part that the gender gap in the tech
industry could be attributed to
biological differences between men and
women at a coding event for teen girls
that evening Pichai encouraged the group
of young women to pursue careers in tech
there's a place for you at Google don't
let anyone tell you otherwise you you
belong here and we need you the engineer
behind the controversial memo James
d'amour was fired from the company and
has since been embraced by several
right-wing groups they say Google
oppresses free speech it's one thing to
be fired for being unpopular it's
another thing for being fired for being
right controversial conservative speaker
Milo you Napoles targeted some of
Google's employees on social media
publicizing their Twitter biographies
Google's diversity VP privatized her
Twitter feed after reportedly receiving
a slew of racist and sexist insults
Google is in a very unusual position
right now you when you have a polarized
workforce and you're talking about
fracturing communication even
I'm sure they're really concerned that
this won't be resolved Pichai is now
reviewing emails from an employee city
actually says the vast majority of them
support his fired up de Bourgh but
others voice concerns about being able
to speak freely at work Google now says
it plans to hold group forums for
employees to discuss their concerns Jeff
Carter thank you